Jenny is in Waco Texas welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show Jenny thank you for
taking my call sure not going to help we
have a third car because my husband just
started a new job at the beginning of
the year that he got a company car for
and that car that he used to drive is
upside down extremely bad it is our
largest debt at 34,000 we have an
opportunity over the next three months
to be able to pay $7,000 on it and our
in-laws my in-laws has offered to pay
$10,000 so that we could trade or turn
that car into Carmack's and I just
didn't know if that's the best
opportunity to get that large debt off
or do I stick with the snowball so the
$10,000 is coming from your in-laws as a
gift
no alone not a chance
we do not borrow money from relatives
okay no absolutely not
so your $7000 upside down in a $34,000
car
18,000 upside down so the car has 34
owed yes how in the world you get that
far upside down you must have rolled
negative from the other one into it it
was yeah it was a mistake on a car
purchase but we were not told that it
was a salvaged car
and so it we had to get rid of it and
they're just snowballed from there
it was a bad mistake so you took a bad
mistake and made it worse
yep okay Wow so extra helpful winter
hours and it's fitting my monthly income
with is 70 325 okay so it's $100,000
your income roughly a hundred hundred
twenty thousand are your income roughly
it just it would take a six hundred and
fifty dollar payment off plus probably
half of our insurance and that we could
be able to roll start rolling early and
dark that credit you've owed our in-laws
before and we don't care there's no way
I'm ever going to tell you tomorrow from
in-laws ever okay the borrower is slave
to the lender and you you just run all
there there is no upside to that only
downside okay they give me the nicest
people in the world it's I thanks giving
dinner doesn't ational the same when you
eat with your master yeah hi so how much
other dad have you guys got we've got
about 105 total including that car
including 34 and what's the rest of it
it's our largest it's bad decisions
living we were living too high for our
so what's the rest of it and on one more
car that's it's just it's not an
expensive car we just uh on it I know we
bought it so much and then I would say
just not credit cards but loan does so
you just have sixty thousand dollars and
fifty thousand dollars in personal loans
yes okay okay so the other car is like
ten grand or something the other car is
[Music]
sorry fourteen you have the ability to
get a personal loan for the hole that
you're in no we tried because yeah we
tried who is the loan with on the car on
that car you know I don't know that one
because my husband hates that though I
don't know who it's with
I'm sorry okay yeah you need to combine
your finances from this point forward
going on to so that you both know what's
going on with all that I just don't know
he pays that's all I know what it is I
just don't know what he pay yeah he does
the paying part and I do the budget part
we both have a hint I mean we is it
right or do you have any idea there's a
bank okay is it a local bank that they
would work with you on the deficit yeah
I'll let you sign a note for the
difference
we have tried I've tried with your
existing lender yes
we've tried everything this was our only
option was to get the 10,000 from his
parents and it's not the only they just
won't give us the full amount because
they don't think we should sell it for
that cheats they think we should try and
sell it so what other people could tell
us where I agree with I agree with that
there's no panic here there's just a lot
of discussed every time you look at it
sit in the drive while you feel stupid
so because that's not a panic there's
nothing that I mean so I agree that you
should sell the car for more and I do
not agree we would ever have you borrow
from them so what would I do
did you where was the 7000 coming from
that's our income oh no no no I thought
you said there were 17 and they were
gonna loan you 10 and where was the
other 7 coming from we have well I get
an extra paycheck this month so between
this month and the next two months we
can pay that policy to get it to where
we can just clean it up but yeah you
know the Carmack's would pay 218 for it
I'm not do not sell it for Carmack's
let's sell it for 22 instead of for 18
or 24 instead of for 18 slow sale but
don't do that until you've got the money
lined up and it sounds like that the
money is going to come from you're
saving up the money to do this and if
you want to do that before you start
really attacking the debt snowball you
can but you know it's not the other
world either way but you know I don't
think I've talked to you out of it but
there's not a chance I'm borrowing the
money from the you've got to quit
borrowing your way out of these things
and you know you're your in-laws at your
age loaning you money oh my gosh you
gotta stop this it's just a bad practice
and you're gonna it's going to bite you
one of these days there's so there's so
many control things and so many things
that happen with that
stuff it's just a bad idea so yeah if
you want to stop your debt snowball and
just say we're gonna get rid of this car
and cover the difference in the next few
months and then start officially start
that snowball you could do that if I
were in your shoes what I do that I
might because you've got insurance
issues and you've got a $600 a month
payment that's clearing up it might be
worth it to get that out of the way and
there's such a level of disgust around
this particular purchase that was a bad
purchase rolled into a bad purchase
rolled into a bad purchase but don't
give the car away for wholesale don't
panic I mean you know you $5,000 a lot
of money in your world right now and
$5,000 more getting for the market for
that car rather than a selling at the
car max is helpful for this situation
and it lowers the amount that you need
to do this so yeah I'm that that's how I
would look at it thanks for thanks for
joining us